days after she was killed in a southwest
valley crash the community came together
tonight to honor tina tintor the 23 year
old and her dog max died when police say
former raider henry ruggs slammed into
her car causing a fiery crash sasha
loftus joins us now from the
intersection where it happened with more
denise and brian this memorial for tina
and max just gets bigger every day it's
really a symbol of the sadness our
entire city feels for these two lives
taken far too soon
sadness and shock blend into anger as
las vegas mourns for tina tintor
everybody i know is mad the 23-year-old
and her dog max were killed in this
horrific dui crash tuesday involving
former raider henry ruggs iii who police
say was driving over 150 miles an hour
dozens gathered for a candlelight vigil
friday some strangers who wanted to pay
their respects and others who called
tina a friend i said you've got to be
kidding me i just broke down mary vogel
worked with her at target and says she
simply had a kind soul that's why it
hurt so bad because
a good-hearted person like that just
taken away so senselessly tina's love
for animals was also honored as a few
brought their pets to visit
with toys and treats for a second life
stolen i think it's touching a lot of
people's hearts that this was
something that didn't happen to happen
though nothing will bring these two back
many hope this unimaginable pain
serves as a reminder
so others don't suffer this same kind of
fate find a friend
get a lift or uber because this is
getting ridiculous
you can see the target name
many of tina's former co-workers were
here they say she worked at the target
store at flamingo and grand canyon in
the same area of town until about march
of 2020
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now